welcome I hope everybody had a good
party last night and good morning so
to it there's going to be no code at all
in this entire presentation so it's a
good warm-up for lunch I guess before I
really start talking about what I'm
going to start talking about I want to
ask you some questions and you don't
have to answer out loud but I want you
to answer to yourself so first I'm going
to ask you to think about going to the
hairdresser I want you to think if you
have ever been actually afraid of going
to the hairdresser actually afraid of
being verbally assaulted even maybe
physically assaulted for going to the
hairdresser and the reason why I asked
this is because this is a problem that
trans people add if you are a trans man
and you go to the hairdresser and they
can tell that you are a trans man then
there have been several episodes of
trans men being assaulted by the
hairdresser because the hairdresser
thinks that they are trying to lure them
to pay less for their haircuts because
male Hil haircuts or haircuts for men
are cheaper than haircuts for women
planning a vacation we've all planned
vacations right that's nice you sit
around thinking do you want to go to the
beach or is a good place to bring the
kids is it expensive how far is it to
fly gay people same-sex couples and
trans people they have to pay attention
to a whole other set of parameters can
they be arrested in this country can
they be killed for being who they are a
whole large portions of the world are
not accessible to go on vacation for
same-sex couple
so the talk is called deconstructing
privilege my name is Patricia oz I am
normally a programmer and the C++
programmer which is a community that is
made mostly consists of men
unfortunately so please if you want to
learn how to program C++ I'm on Twitter
but during the last few months I've been
helping form an organization is called a
hash include' C++ and it's basically to
try to help with diversity and inclusion
in C++ and I'm not going to talk about
that at all but if you're interested I'm
on Twitter so what I'm going to start
with and this is the foundation of the
talk but I'm not going to talk it's not
the meat of the talk but it's the
foundation of the talk so it's the four
stages of competence and most people are
familiar with this it's basically the
idea of going from something unconscious
incompetence so you are not aware that
you don't know so these are the famous
unknown unknowns the things that you
don't know that you're incompetent in as
people might call you ignorant in this
stage but basically your intuition is
wrong you think you have an intuition
and you think it's right but it's
actually wrong the the difficult part of
being unconscious and competence is that
you don't know that this is where you
are so when you move from there to the
next stage you come to conscious and
competence and conscience and Compton's
you know that you don't know what you're
talking about
it's a good start it's a really good
start because that's when you start to
do your research right that's when you
start to learn and when you've done your
research and you've done everything and
you you're just starting to get into the
topic then you're moving over to
conscious competence you're actually you
have the data you form conclusions you
have a sound analysis the thing is that
it seems like this is something that
will flow naturally into the last column
this unconscious competence but in my
experience that most people will never
be able to bridge the gap between con
just competence and unconscious
competence and I'll give you an example
and why that is difficult so we're going
to swear in a form foreign language this
is I'm using this example because most
people can relate to this example right
if you learn the language you don't know
anything in most people if you learn
less than ten words in the language a
few of those will be swear words that is
just what people do right and it's kind
of fun to swear in a foreign language
especially those under ten words
languages because you don't know
anything else and it's kind of fun as
you learn more of a language then you're
starting to wonder maybe this is
offensive maybe I shouldn't do this
actually I don't know how offensive this
thing is and then you're starting to
wonder you know like okay so maybe I
should talk to people who speak this
language you know and then you're slowly
but surely building up something to a
point where you're quite fluent in the
language and it's definitely offensive
there's like no doubt this is definitely
offensive I should not say this thing
but there is there has been studies done
on people who speak a language as their
native language and people who are very
fluent in that language but it's not
their native language and how they react
to swear words and people are our native
language speakers this is their language
they have they have an actual physical
reaction they have cortisol levels
rising when people swear and that
doesn't happen even though you're really
really fluent if it's not your mother
tongue you don't have that same reaction
so if you notice here that in when
you're consciously competent you go like
that is definitely offensive but when
you're caught unconscious competent in
this language you just say that's rude
you don't say that that's rude and when
people say but why like like for example
in English the in English using the word
bloody can be very rude which in most of
the language you're gonna like okay I
don't know why that's rude but it is
rude and a native of the speaker will
just say it's rude I can't tell you why
it's rude it just is
and that's why I'm saying going from
being consciously competent to being
unconsciously competent it's very
difficult because you are basically
talking to someone who has it ingrained
and who they are and it's not
necessarily something that you're able
to do so I'm saying don't aim for that
aim for consciously competent it's a
good goal so we're going to talk of our
privilege today and we can imagine being
unconsciously incompetent in this topic
you will say privilege is a myth I don't
believe this is a problem because I
don't experience this and this is again
of wrong intuition because you're
measuring somebody else's experience
through your own experience and if you
don't experience what they are
experiencing then your intuition is
wrong
this is very difficult and that is a big
part of what I'm going to try to
convince you of today that there are
people around you who live a lived
experience that is completely different
from yours in many central aspects and
when you realize that their lived life
is different from yours then you realize
also that you don't know anything about
their life and the good thing about
becoming consciously incompetent and it
seems like a very low goal but it is
central goal it's because you start
listening to people you start wanting to
learn from them and so that is the whole
build-up of the talk but we're gonna
start from the beginning because what is
privileged I've used to read several
times but what does it mean and what did
I mean by it when I say it most people
have experienced hardship you'd be
surprised on people that you work with
every day and the things that they carry
around inside of them that you don't
know real massive pains and troubles
that they have now or they've had in the
past that you don't know about most
people have experienced hardship many
people have not lived
good lives but it can't tell but
privilege is being spared a particular
type of hardship your life might not
have been great but this specific thing
you didn't get that one when you talk
about your partner you're talking about
maybe you're going to go on vacation or
that your partner is applying for new
jobs or that your partner is making
dinner for you do you worry about what
word what pronoun you use when you talk
about your partner is this something
that gives you a knot in your stomach
that you're afraid that you're going to
say the wrong thing one day and the
consequences for for a same-sex couple
could be massive it depends on where you
live and it depends on the environment
that you're in I
it could be something small as being
ostracized if people talk about you
behind your back Scotty no but it could
be massive it could be in the wrong
place
somebody's you're in a bar with your
colleagues and somebody screams oh my
god you're gay and then you this late at
night you have to walk from their home
this could result in you being
physically assaulted but this is not
something that heterosexual couples
worry about as anyone of work ever asked
you how you have sex with your partner
this is a ridiculous thing like why
would anyone do this it's a crazy thing
like how do you physically have sex with
your partner it doesn't make any sense
this happens to it happens to gay people
or average the same sex couples but it
also happens a lot even more to
transsexual people people have for some
reason think it is perfectly fine to ask
a transsexual person how they have sex
with their partner it's like you don't
know this person you're walking up and
asking them physiologically excuse me
but I want to know what happens
underneath the covers
if you asked a heterosexual person this
question that look like what is wrong
with you but for some reason people
think this is perfectly acceptable to
ask transsexual people has anyone at
work ever comes it on your weight said
you know what you could afford to lose
some pounds you know or I think you're
getting like you're getting a little bit
fat aren't you or even you've lost a lot
of weight
are you anorexic what's wrong with you
why why I'm God
I don't know why anybody would think
this was any other business but for some
reason people have made it socially
acceptable to bully people that are
overweight especially but even people
who are underweight and you don't know
why somebody is underweight they could
be safe and they might not want to talk
about that with you has anyone at work
ever asked you what your genitalia looks
like this is kind of crazy right it's
like excuse me John I was wondering this
happens to transsexual people and
transgender people all the time all the
time it's so that they I get tired of
hearing this question some question you
have never gotten in your entire life is
something that transgender people are
tired of hearing it's not just once it's
because people want to know like excuse
me but I'd like to know what you look
like naked I'm like it's none of your
business we're never gonna have anything
has anyone ever shushed you in a meeting
you're sitting there with your
colleagues and you're talking and at
certain points um it goes like she
happens to women all the time
women get constantly shush to meetings
I've never seen a man be shushed in my
entire life
I've seen men do the crazy in
meetings they have been screaming
yelling banging the table with and all
sorts of things like and calling people
names I've seen in meetings I've never
seen the man being shushed
I've been just many times never done any
of the previous things are you expected
to always be meek and accommodating this
is this is something that hits women
very hard we're supposed to be nice if
we are not always accommodating to the
people around us if we are not like
excuse me I'm alive I'm excuse me I'm
here excuse me that I'm not talking if
we are not apologetic for it opening our
mouths people think we are rude people
think we are angry if we don't have a
smile on our face we are accused of
being angry and if you can get some
things like maybe you should smile a
little more people would like you more
you should say that to all your male
colleagues I'm sure they'll appreciate
it this is also something that they end
up doing a lot of what is considered to
be office housework like you know like
Jane can you go get the coffee or you
know Joan can you take notes all of
those things that you end up having the
single woman in your team doing all
sorts of chores for you like she was
your mother are certain jobs unavailable
to you because of language our accent
many people who are not living in their
birth country might have problems
getting jobs because of language accent
not knowing the language well enough to
have these jobs which means that the
number of jobs they can take is very
limited this makes them vulnerable right
because now they can't leave a toxic
environment necessarily because it's
very hard to get another job
vulnerable people who have a trouble
getting other jobs could be other people
as well people with physical
disabilities might be very afraid of
trying to change jobs do people ridicule
you as a parent because of your gender
this is something that happens to men a
lot somehow it is okay to laugh at men
being bad parents you would never laugh
at a female colleague and the butt of
the joke is that she's a bad mother
right but for some reason we make fun of
men as parents and men often suffer as
parents in many contexts they're not
taking seriously if the doctor calls
because of something they'll often call
the mother even though the father's
father was the one that brought the
child they will still call the mother
kindergarten will do the same men will
be be be spoken down to in any kind of
situation dealing with government and
they will often talk with the mother
this is a very painful topic for men who
want to be engaged in their children's
lives because it happens again and again
and then you go to work and then
somebody makes fun of your saying men
can dress their kids and you're gonna
like when I bring my kids to
kindergarten every frickin morning
that's my that's what I do I make lunch
and I you just my kid of course I can
dress my kid why would this be funny do
you get time off free of religious
holidays I asked my husband this and he
said no he's an atheist so I told him
you got extra um but in Norway for
example the the Christian holidays you
get everybody a small but what if you're
Muslim so you might be entitled to get
unpaid leave off for your religious
holidays but you'll see that these
things are not the same because in
Norway if you work on a Christian
holiday you get extra pay because this
is like an inconvenience too because we
assume that everyone is celebrating a
Christian holiday but what about having
to be forced to work on your religious
holidays you don't get compensated for
that
do people refuse to use your name and
instead use a painful name you can try
to imagine this as somebody actively
using a bully name like something that
you recalled as a child that hurt this
is something that happens a lot to
transgender people it's something that
they called dead naming it's people who
refuse to use their chosen name and
keeps on using the name that they had
before their transition transition this
is very painful and it's painful even in
ways that you might not imagine like
imagine that your transition at work so
you have lots of commits in the codebase
with your old name and it keeps coming
up like you're editing files and this
name will keep on and this is an
incredibly painful thing for transgender
people have you ever worried that about
whether you could attend an event at all
and if you notice these beautiful
beautiful stairs here you don't have to
have that many stairs before a person in
a wheelchair can't attend you need one
step
but even if we take away the
accessibility part as well then you end
up with women often choosing not to
attend professional contexts that
involve alcohol because they know that
when their colleagues drink they might
be sexually harassed and they don't want
that even even you don't want that for
yourself but you don't really want to
face that person next day so you don't
really want that for them either you
don't want them to be that and that is
going to be at work and it's never going
to stop this person will always be
awkward because they know they did this
thing and now it's your problem because
now this person won't work with you
anymore
and this whole thing can just kind of
escalate much further than this one
party but also you have to walk home
from this place right alone because when
you go to a professional context you're
generally not going with your partner so
now you're going home alone at night so
you might think you know what I'm just
gonna leave after dinner after one drink
while everybody's pretty pretty sober
I'm just gonna go home has anyone asked
you if you belonged at an event this
happens to a lot of people for different
reasons for some reason people think
that you don't look the part you don't
look like you belong and that could be
because you're a woman it could be
because you have dark skin it could be
for many different reasons that people
will assume that you are not technical
or maybe that your staff or even worse
that you're a booth babe because you're
wearing a dress so we've talked about
privileges and I'm going to list some
types of privileges and then you can
think about to yourself what kinds of
privileges you might have because that
is my point here we all have some types
of privileges in some ways we have all
been spared so you will have sexual
orientation where a heterosexuality has
his triumph and dictating also
to popular culture but gender identity
and gender identity here I'm saying that
do you identify with your birth gender
the one you were assigned at birth if
you do that is generally called
cisgender that means you're not
transgender if your sister that's
generally a much easier path in life
then you have your gender men will in
some cases have it easier than women and
and in easier than non-binary or other
types of gender identities but not
always like we saw with being parents
sometimes it sucks to be a man to
ability are you able bodied because this
could be a big deal like I read about a
company that said that all the employees
had to have standing desks in this
business having back problems is like
very common imagine that you had to
stand all day at work or I don't know I
don't know what she do age for some
reason in this business people think
that working hard in a field for ten
twenty thirty years for somehow makes
you less competent I'm not really sure
how that works for some reason we think
that young people in their early 20s are
extremely brilliant whereas they
generally don't know much but they have
a lot of confidence I'll give them that
but that generally comes with
unconscious company incompetence okay
people think they know everything then
you have racial racial or ethnic if
people can tell looking at you that you
are not white then this can cause you
friction in many cases many people will
often think that you are more angry
people might be especially especially
dark-skinned men might have the problem
that they can never ever raise their
voice they can never be angry at all or
in
anyway because people become afraid of
them so they are generally the nicest
kindest most soft-spoken people you find
because they have to compensate from
that bias and everybody else language
we've talked a little bit about language
but speaking the language or speaking
the language well can be a
differentiator citizenship this is
another one that is kind of scary
because again it comes to options right
if you have moved your family to a
country and you're living there and in
the entire residency and you're living
in this country in your family living in
this country hinges on this one job are
you going to risk it to speak up when
people are harassing you it will work
and then you have religion especially if
the religion is somehow visible in your
clothing but then you have something
that most people can probably relate to
social economic background class accent
education things that might open doors
for you or close them if you grew up
there are things that most people don't
think about if you grow up poor you
really don't know how to behave in these
upperclassmen contexts you don't know
how to eat in a fancy restaurant cuz you
never eaten in a fancy restaurant your
life you don't know how to to save or
invest or any of these things and you
can't ask your family because nobody any
family knows either but this is the last
one and I think it shows exactly how
arbitrary privilege is really it is
something that is called passing
privilege and you can have that in any
of these categories you can have passing
privilege passing privilege means that
when people look at you they think you
have this they think you have this
privilege and because they think so you
have it you know that these things might
not be true like for example people
might look at you and think you're
able-bodied
but they might not know that you have a
chronic disease and that means that you
are struggling every day taking and
taking IV drips in the morning and and
that night and you have to take constant
medication and you might die any minute
but people can't tell looking at you and
so you might be able to pass I grew up
with passing privilege I am a half Latin
American half Norwegian I am the whitest
person you have ever met but I was not
the only one who grew up half Norwegian
half Latin American we were a bunch of
kids that did I am the whitest one and
there was a gradient but I have to tell
you that each and every one except me
grew up facing racism from grown ups and
other kids all through our lives they
faced racism being told things like they
couldn't participate in the 17th of May
parade because they weren't Norwegian do
you think I was ever told anything like
that I had a guy in my class who was a
nationalist that's what they called
themselves when they don't want to say
what they are he liked me he really
liked me here and he was really always
super nice to me he knew that I was only
half Norwegian but I was different
that's what they say yeah yeah yeah
everybody all of those people I like
that but not you because you're
different because it's always the ones
that you know that are different right
so I have passing privilege and in
several other ways as well but we can
get into that and another another talk I
guess but basically I can pass in many
ways and that makes me very privileged
because it means that I can live with
with these advantages right but it also
means that I grew up feeling ashamed I
was ashamed of being white because my
life was easier
because privilege is being spared a
hardship I felt ashamed because I didn't
share that hardship with the other kids
that's a strange thing saying I should
suffer like you because because what we
really want to do instead is to say then
I don't want you to suffer either you
should have it as good as me so
privileged to be saying that you're a
privileged can give you that idea that I
want you to have it like me you
shouldn't have that shitty you shouldn't
have this hardship because your skin is
darker or because your gender is
different than mine I want you to have
as as good as me this is the hardest
part of the talk because this is the one
that's probably going to make people
angry and uncomfortable but I want to do
it now because the thing is when you go
out from this talk I want you to go and
I want you to listen to people and I
want you to learn from them but then I
want you to also be conscious of how you
speak could be problematic for them so
we're gonna look at some patterns and
problematic communication and then I'm
going to show you some examples patterns
and problematic communication I got
these they're inspired from a thread and
threads in that thread and so on from a
woman called Erin Brooke and she talks
about a competitive communication style
so I'm going to go through them one at a
time so come in a competitive
communication style the point is to win
you're in there to win then you're not
in it to learn from the other person in
it to win so so in some way you can
change what you're arguing about you can
try to reframe what they're saying the
whole point in the entire talk or
conversation is to somehow make them
lose it's not a learning activity it's
it
the destructive activity you're trying
to win I have I have a saying I say to
my daughter as from dr. Phil is one of
the good things dr. Phil has ever said
he has he said once do you want to be
right or do you want to be married this
is this is the point that with a
competitive communication style the
point is to destroy your opponent if
your opponent is your wife this is not a
good thing do you want to be right or do
you want to be married she has
interpreted this to mean something for
the entire world this is a metaphor in
our family anyway the second one is
downplaying issues and concerns so
downplaying issues and concerns you're
basically saying it's not that bad you
know calm down you're overreacting
don't be so dramatic basically I don't
believe you
third one is interpreting people of
color and women as angry you have to be
so super nice all the time as a woman
and as a person of color because if not
people will interpret you as angry
remember what I said about the men in
the meeting screaming and shouting and
banging the table they were passionate
when I grow up I want to be passionate
because because I can hardly even get a
stern tone before people tell me to calm
down and the last one is not trusting
women's experiences and expertise and
this is something that I think you have
to think about over time like like when
a woman says something to you and you
distrust it a little bit try to think if
a man told you this thing would you feel
the same way because this thing is built
into the fabric of our societies we
think women exaggerate we think women
don't speak the truth we think they are
framing it in some way so we stop
listening and we tell them you know what
it's not that bad don't be so dramatic
okay so now we're going to look at some
examples
what you should notice is that these
things are rarely done accidentally are
in good faith people pretend they're in
good faith and people pretend they're
done accidentally but they're generally
not but it doesn't mean that you meant
it badly but you meant it
and they're often paired with a refusal
to back off when you notice somebody is
being hurt somebody is being damaged by
your communication style you just
continue go on so you have C lining C
lining is named after cartoon so I'll
put up the cartoon and then I read the
cartoon and it has three voices and so
that's gonna be hard but I'll try it
okay so you have a man and a woman
they're sitting in like this toy train
and the woman says I don't mind most
marine mammals but sea lions I could do
without sea lions and the man says don't
say that out loud and then the sea lion
appears of course say pardon me I
couldn't help but overhear now you've
done it says the man I would like to
have a civil conversation about your
statement would you mind showing me
evidence of any negative thing as the
any sea lion has ever done to you go
away there's no need to raise your voice
I'm right here
I just I'm just curious if you have any
sources to back up your opinion you're
in my house you made a statement in
public for all to hear
are you unable to defend the statements
you make or simply I'm willing to have a
reasoned discussion I told you dude
sea lions I have been unfailingly polite
and you two have been nothing but rude
I'm trying to eat breakfast very well we
shall resume in an hour so let's have a
textual description of this sea lion is
a type of trolling or harassment which
consists of pursuing people with
persistent requests for evidence or
repeated questions
the
rather who uses his tactic also uses
fake civility asked to discredit their
target and will get a little bit back to
this fake civility and this kind of tone
and this is the hard part huh
mansplaining a lot of people get really
stuck on the man part of mansplaining
but mansplaining does not talk about men
explaining things but it is a specific
form of communication it is an actual
situation that is being described not
men explaining things we should have
like a thing men explaining things ok
sorry I got distracted ok the technical
that this is from Aaron Brooks she wrote
an article which was based sort of on
the Twitter thread from earlier and the
technical definition of mansplaining is
when a man explains something to a woman
she already knows often Anakin's
condescending tone this often doesn't
really bring to the table exactly how
this is is generally explaining her
specific expertise her field like like
somebody come in it's like no you don't
know anything about it and she wrote the
book right it's like I'm going to
explain to you how this works and it's
like yeah you know that ok this book I
wrote that book but it can also be
something like a man trying to explain
women how periods work which we always
appreciate but before we continue I want
to talk about something back to swearing
again when people are in pain most
peoples where even people are deadly
polite and all sorts of other
circumstances might actually swear and
might not be like a big swear but might
be a little swear but most people swear
when they are in pain so imagine that
you know you cut your leg let's do
something really macho so you were
chopping wood see you know and and the
cutting your leg made is basically you
chopped into it like right so you're
here like they're rolling into the
hospital and you're like in massive pain
you're screaming and swearing and you're
basically like ok I I don't know how
sailors swear but let's assume that it
was massive right
and then the doctor comes and goes like
okay you need to calm down you need to
talk to me no no I don't want any of
that swearing okay it's like I will not
no calm down no I will not be able to
talk to you until you talk like a normal
plate person this is crazy right you
would never do this you know this person
is in pain you don't care if they're
swearing you don't care if they're
screaming you're basically asking okay
so this where does it hurt it's like it
doesn't matter right because you know
you see through it and you realize that
these expressions that swearing and the
screaming they're basically conveying a
underlying pain right so that brings us
to tone policing tone policing of
visitors definition drawing attention to
the tone rather than content of a
statement can allow other parties to
avoid engaging with sound arguments
presented in that statement thus
undermining the originals party's
attempt to communicate and effectively
shutting them down I will not listen to
you until you stop screaming what you
will see when you talk and listen to
people who have been victims of
systematic discrimination their entire
lives as they are often in pain and they
are often angry and you know what they
have good reason to be like when you
chopped your leg okay this is they have
good reason to be and sometimes to some
of the things that they will say will be
hurtful to you because they it hits you
they might say things like I hate all
men or or white women are you have
to get over that feeling of being
defensive over that feeling of I'm not
like that because that is very difficult
thing to get over and realize that these
people are in pain
and try to listen to what they're
actually saying a good example of this
or a reaction that I don't want you to
have is not all men because this is a
form of tone policing if people are
saying men are like this or men are like
that and they are in a group where they
have been living with systematic
discrimination their entire life they
know not all men are like that
this is an expression of desperation as
an expression of pain as an expression
of hurt and what you need to start doing
is listening to what are they actually
expressing what are their feelings what
are the experience that they're talking
about and not take it personally they're
not talking about you but by focusing on
yourself by saying yeah but I'm not like
this you're taking the microwave
microphone away from someone who really
we all need to listen to because they
are expressing and they are brave enough
to say out loud something we all need to
hear and yes they're angry but remember
when in pain most people swear they're
angry
that's alright doesn't mean you should
stop listening so let's go back to the
patterns of problematic communication
competitive communication style you're
out to win win over this person and
generally this person is someone who's
already suffered right you're
downplaying their issues and concerns
you're basically saying it's not that
bad I don't really believe you you're
interpreting people as angry when
they're actually in pain and you're not
trusting women's experiences and
expertise you're saying you know what I
don't think you actually know anything I
know how it is to be a woman better than
you but what can you do
remember this drawing about privilege
azimuth and then we come to privilege
might be real
hopefully I'm gotten you to the point
that you know privilege might be real
there might be something to this and
then I hope I'll get you to this I
believe this might be a problem but I
don't understand it and that will make
you listen to people that will make you
seek them out because that's what I want
you to do start listening to people
educating yourself be aware that
situations that you experience as
uneventful like going to the hairdresser
or planning a vacation can be hostile or
even dangerous to other people you can't
imagine what it's like because you have
never lived that life their life is
different from yours and their life is
different for no other reason than their
gender their gender identity their
sexuality their skin color physical or
psychological disability nothing of any
fault of their own they have suffered
pains that you did not because you were
lucky and you got another thing so
educate yourself and by educating
yourself I mean Google there's like lots
of stuff to read there's lots of videos
to watch follow lots of people from
underrepresented groups on Twitter and
listen to what they say but don't ask
them to explain don't demand that they
will educate you they have enough on
their plate and just be grateful that
they're bothering to say it out loud so
that you have the possibility to learn
and then in your local little bubble at
work you have a concept of lending
privilege lending privileges using your
privilege to you lift somebody else up
if you know that you have respect you
have power at work people respect you
people listen to you you can use that to
bring somebody else with you
say that you know what on this new
projects which is really exciting I
really want
Joan to help me I think she's brilliant
and that is using your privilege your
power your social capital to help
someone else get opportunities that they
might not otherwise have gotten you
react when they're ignored in a meeting
you know when somebody says something
and nobody reacts to it go like I think
that what Jane just said was great I
thought that is a really good idea that
is using your social capital it's not
being angry you don't have to be angry
but you're using your status to lift
somebody else call out your peers on
their prejudice if people are sitting
around in a corner discussing you know
whether or not they thought that some
female speaker was hot you know like you
know what I don't think that's an
appropriate way to talk about her I
think she's brilliant and I don't like
that you do that again you don't have to
be really bad you don't have to do to
burn all of many social bridges and you
can support them by sponsoring their
careers and when I say sponsoring is
different than mentoring sponsoring is
basically you're burning your own
capital for this you're saying that for
these jobs for this position
I recommend this person I think there's
really smart and now you are actually
putting your reputation on the line for
somebody else this is not something that
is without cost but that is a way that
you can use that power that leverage
that you have and since we have a little
bit of time I want to play a little
video for you so let's see see if I can
[Music]
take two steps forward if you grew up
with a father figure in the home
take two steps forward if you had access
to a private education
to a free tutor growing up
take two steps forward if you've never
had to worry about your cell phone being
shut up
take two steps forward if you never had
a help mom or dad with the bills take
two steps forward if it wasn't because
of your athletic ability you don't have
to pay for college
take two steps forward if you never
wanted where your next meal was going to
come from
I want you guys up here in the front
just to turn around look every statement
I've made has nothing to do with
anything any of you have done has
nothing to do with decisions you've made
everything I've said has nothing to do
with what you've done we all know these
people up here have a better opportunity
to win this hundred dollars does that
mean these people back here can't race
no we would be foolish to not realize
we've been given more opportunity we
don't want to recognize that we've been
given a head start but the reality is we
have now there's no excuse they still
got to run that race
you still got to run your race but
whoever wins this hundred dollars I
think it'd be extremely foolish of you
not to utilize that and learn more about
somebody else's story because what you
see is privileges being spared a
hardship but it is also a compound
interest you have one then you have
another the more you have the better it
is these things stack up being white
yeah I give that gives you privilege
being white man gives you more getting
being a white straight man gives you
even more these things stack up and so
people are not starting from a level
playing field there is no level playing
field but none of this means that your
life was easy just because you have one
or many of these privileges doesn't mean
your life was easy it just means that
these specific burdens you were spared
for those you were spared from those but
as we all become aware of our privileges
it opens us up to listening it opens us
up to learning from others and that is
how we become better people that is how
we become better
partners that's how we become better
colleagues and that is my talk thank you
if you have any questions you can come
and talk to me after the talk thank you